it's been a busy week in the continuing
effort to gain more control over the
covid pandemic an fda advisory panel
recommended booster shots of two more
vaccines for millions of americans and
they will consider whether it's safe for
people to mix and match to get initial
doses of one vaccine and then boosters
of another
meanwhile the battle over vaccine
mandates whether government agencies and
private businesses can order workers to
get shots continues to escalate and
there are growing signs some essential
workers may stay off the job
rather than comply with mandates
we want to discuss all this plus get the
latest on the spread of the virus with
dr anthony fauci the white house chief
medical advisor doctor welcome back to
fox news sunday
thank you thank you chris good to be
with you as we say the fda advisory
panel this week recommended
application for the use of the two
other boosters that hadn't been approved
so far moderna and jnj even though the
data
on jnj boosters was relatively speaking
pretty weak according to some of the
scientists on that panel has the
politics of giving boosters gotten ahead
of the actual public health
well you know chris i'm not so sure the
pollux got politics got ahead of it if
you look at the data that's been
accumulated not only from our cohorts
that we're following here in the united
states
but the information which is critical
information that we're getting from
israel is very very clear that there's
waning immunity and that we do need to
boost individuals who've received any of
the three products that we've uh been
dealing with right now and as you
mentioned just this past week two of
them
moderna and jay and jay uh put their
data before the fda and their advisory
committee has made a recommendation now
it's up to the fda to make that
authorization which i believe will then
go on for a recommendation from the cdc
so i don't think there's any political
issue there i think it's just public
health data and evidence the fda panel
will now also consider whether it is
safe to mix and match to get
your initial dose from one vaccine and
then your booster from another vaccine
this is especially an issue with jnj
which according to the data has offers
less protection first of all do you
think mix and match is safe
and should people who got the jnj
vaccine initially
seriously consider getting a booster of
another vaccine which offers more
protection
well i think what needs to be done and i
believe it will be done chris is that
there'll be a degree of flexibility that
will be left up to the individual based
on their individual situation the point
that you make is as follows if you look
at the data
from j and j that presented to the fda
when they use their own product as the
boost it's based on clinical data from a
clinical trial the mix and match to
which you refer
shows that when you boost moderna or
fisa against the original j and j
you get a much higher antibody level
that's a laboratory indicator that would
predict
efficacy but it's a laboratory data so
people need to understand that the j and
j against the j and j from the trial and
the data they presented is based on
clinical data so what you're going to
see
without a doubt
is that the fda is going to take all of
that under advisement from their
advisory committee
and then they'll make a regulatory
decision which will then will get to the
cdc with their advisory committee and
they'll make a recommendation i believe
there's going to be a degree of
flexibility of what a person who got the
j and j originally can do either with j
and j or with the mix and match from
other products doctor let's take a look
at where we are now in this fourth wave
of the coronavirus there's an average of
almost 84 000 new cases every day and
more than 1500 deaths every day still
bad but down considerably
from a month ago are we coming out of
the delta wave and as we head into
colder weather
people going inside holiday travel
what is the real possibility that we
could have a fifth wave of the virus
especially especially if there's not a
spike in vaccinations
well that's the issue i think what you
just mentioned just now chris it's going
to be within our capability to prevent
that from happening you're right the
numbers are going down the cases are
down about 23
the hospitalizations and deaths are down
17 or 18 percent
so we're going in the right direction
the problem is as we all know
we still have approximately 66 million
people who are eligible to be vaccinated
who are not vaccinated the degree to
which we continue to come down in that
slope will depend on how well we do
about getting more people vaccinated if
we don't do very well in that regard
there's always the danger that there'll
be enough circulating virus that you can
have a stalling of the diminishing of
the number of cases and when that
happens
as we've seen in the past with other
waves that we've been through there's
the danger of resurgence but we can do
something about that that's the whole
point that we keep emphasizing the more
people we get vaccinated the less
likelihood is there going to be another
surge as we go into the winter so
briefly what is your advice
for the holiday season for travel for
gathering together as families first for
groups that are vaccinated and then for
groups that alright
well for groups that are vaccinated i
think we can enjoy the holiday season i
get asked that all the time you know
trick-or-treating in halloween
thanksgiving with the family when you're
in the family unit among people who are
vaccinated i think you should just enjoy
the holidays as best you can in the
family spirit for those who are not
vaccinated first i would encourage them
very strongly to get vaccinated but if
they're not they should do what the cdc
recommends is when you're in an indoor
setting in a public indoor setting to
wear a mask it's very important we know
that masks work and they could greatly
diminish the likelihood that you're
going to get infected which is another
reason why we keep saying
why it's so important to get vaccinated
because not only will it be good for
your own health and that of your family
it will make it much easier for you to
enjoy the kinds of things in society
that you'd like to enjoy anyway well let
me pick up on that doctor texas governor
greg abbott this week issued an
executive order banning any entity
whether public or private
from mandating that people get vaccines
here he was last june when he banned
vaccine passports take a look
texas is open 100 percent
and we want to make sure that you have
the freedom
to go where you want
without limits
what do you think of governor rabbit
well i'm not going to make an opinion
about my personal opinion of any person
in office like a governor except to say
that from a public health standpoint
that is really unfortunate because we
know
how effective vaccines are in preventing
not only illness for the individual
but for diminishing the dynamics of the
infection in society the data are very
very clear it doesn't matter what i
think or not think of governor abbott
the fact is look at the data and look at
the difference between people who get
vaccinated versus of people who are
unvaccinated in cases in
hospitalizations and in deaths the cdc
just came out with their recent data and
the data are really striking chris about
the risk associated with being
unvaccinated versus the protection that
you get when you are vaccinated so i
would have to just you know
go ahead no go ahead finish your
sentence
no no i was going to say so
unfortunately i can understand perhaps
what the governor is trying to do but i
think when you're in a public health
crisis
sometimes unusual situations require
unusual actions and in this case it's
things like mandating be they masks or
vaccinations they're very important
we're not living in a vacuum as
individuals we're living in a society
and society needs to be protected and
you do that by not only protecting
yourself but by protecting the people
around you by getting vaccinated i want
to squeeze in two more questions
in a number of places
police
pilots
health workers are threatening job
action if vaccine mandates are enforced
i want you to take a look at the
police union official in chicago and
then the mayor of that city here they
are
it's safe to say the city of chicago
will have a police force at 50 percent
or less
for this weekend coming up if those who
are sworn to uphold the law
act as if they're above the law
we're not going to tolerate that that's
not acceptable
when we're talking about essential
workers maybe going off the job like
half of a police force should local
officials or should corporate executives
back off enforcing these mandates
well chris i mean
i'm not comfortable with telling people
what they should do under normal
circumstances
but we are not in normal circumstances
right now take the police we know now
the statistics more police officers die
of covid than they do in other causes of
death so
it doesn't make any sense to not trying
to protect yourself
as well as the colleagues that you work
with so i i think if we can get people
to just think about that think about the
implications
of not getting vaccinated when you're in
a position
where you have a responsible job and you
want to protect yourself because you're
needed at your job whether you're a
police officer or a pilot or any other
of those kinds of occupations
finally
when this pandemic started
i think it's fair to say you were the
generally regarded as the
authority on infectious disease but as
time has gone on you have become
a polarizing figure critics accuse you
of sending mixed messages there's
allegations that that you help fund
dangerous research at the wuhan lab
two questions why do you think
you've become so controversial and
honestly do you think there's anything
you have done that has contributed to
that
well i'm not so sure i could answer the
latter because i can't think of anything
but i'm sure some people will
but you know chris i have stood for
always making science data and evidence
be what we guide ourselves by
and i think people who feel differently
who have conspiracy theories who deny
reality that's looking them straight in
the eye
those are people that don't particularly
care for me and that's understandable
because what i do and i try very hard is
to be guided by the truth and sometimes
the truth becomes inconvenient for some
people so they react against me
that just is what it is there's not much
i can do about that chris dr fauci thank
you thanks for your time this sunday
it's always good to talk with you sir
same here chris thank you for having me